if Republicans don't take back the house
that that'll be a bit concerned because
if they can't do it in this environment
I don't think they can ever do it hi I'm
Nick Gillespie for reason TV and today
we're talking with Chris Chocola the
president of the club for growth Chris
thanks for joining us to be here what is
the club for growth well we are a
membership organization 55,000 members
that are really United in one belief and
that's it pro-growth policies lead to
prosperity for everybody who are the
candidates that you guys are backing in
this cycle that you're most excited
about I'm really excited about the
Senate as a whole when you think about
the fact that there are great candidates
like Rand Paul Pat Toomey Marco Rubio
Ron Johnson in Wisconsin I'm going to
forget a sharon angle in Nevada ken buck
in Colorado the list goes on and on
where you know Jim DeMint could end up
being the fourth or fifth most
conservative member of the Senate which
is a mind-boggling thought but what
could happen who are you most
antagonistic towards this time around
well you know it kind of starts with
unprincipled career politicians people
like Arlen Specter and charlie Crist
Arlen Specter is no he's gone in the
peel he goes to me beat him right yeah
charlie Crist is changed parties and
Marco Rubio is a great candidate and
then we kind of moved to career
politicians with the wrong principles
people like russ feingold Harry Reid
that I think have very challenging races
and because I think they're out of step
with what America wants right now and
they've really shown that they are not I
mean they're true they're true liberals
and they believe in government over the
power of the markets and people what's
your gut say about the midterms what do
you what do you think is going to happen
in terms of large shifts well I think
the Republicans should take over the
house
the concern I have is that the
expectation has been created and they
can't exceed it they can only fall short
of it now if Republicans don't take back
the house that that will be a big
concern because if they can't do it in
this environment I don't think they can
ever do it but it may be even bigger
concern is if they do take back the
house is it leadership really ready for
the majority again is the leadership
able to learn the lessons of 2006 2008
yeah I was going to ask is it a good
thing if the GOP regains power this
quickly or do they need more time in the
wilderness when you think of somebody
like John Boehner a couple weeks ago on
Meet the Press he couldn't name anything
he was willing to cut is that a
indicator that the Republicans are not
serious about governing I think it's an
indication that all the lessons have not
been learned you know just yesterday
eric cantor came out and said well maybe
the republicans will start earmarking
again and so I don't think they've
learned or listen to the American people
on that issue so but with the good news
is if they take back the majority is
that there will be a large group of new
faces this is the next generation of
leadership and these people are running
for I think all the right reasons they
bring the right values to serve in
Congress and I think the trend will be
much better if the Republicans have not
necessarily learned anything from the
past decade the Democrats haven't but
has the country and have voters and are
they starting to understand you know
that spending is actually an issue and
that pro-growth economic policies matter
on some level you know when I was a
member of Congress I did 150 town hall
meetings and I had as many as zero
people show up at my town hall meetings
but what we see going on I became
cynical that people weren't interested
in good government but what we see with
the tea parties with the town hall
meetings now is people are paying
attention they do understand that the
debt and the deficit really matter and
so I think that that's a great sign that
people are focusing in on good
government they're getting involved in
the process they understand you get what
you you vote for and they're trying to
find people that reflect their values
and you know I think a large segment of
the country believes in limited
government and in fiscal responsibility
yeah whether republic or Democrat and
they're looking for those candidates and
that's the message i hope washington get
you serve two terms as congressman from
indiana talk a little bit about i know
you ran once
lost than you serve two terms then lost
what what's it like to lose a
congressional election well my first
race was my most fun race I lost that
race but you know and you lost in 2006
unless I was a big turnover year right I
represent a Democrat district
conservative Democrats but they let me
sneak in for a couple terms you know it
I never intended on becoming a career
politician it was a great experience but
like I said what I learned was it's all
about who pushes the button and where do
they get to push the button for when you
go to the floor of the house and you
vote and you go the Senate in vote and
so the club for growth what we try to do
is improve the gene pool of Congress we
understand who serves matters and we
understand that you have to have people
that bring principal to Washington
because as the saying goes if you don't
bring it to Washington you're not going
to find it there and so the you know
being through the elective process
winning and losing i think is is great
life experience but i think it certainly
helps me with the club for growth
understand how campaigns work and why it
really matters who serves and i guess it
gives your children something that can
always her let you during an argument
you know that's it they they do but you
know they've ended up okay despite the
whole thing here's a question for you as
a as a former congressman what how hard
is it you know under you know when bush
was in power you're a congressman how
hard is it to fight back against massive
spending increase because that seems to
be the real issue and Bush certainly
worked the ropes a lot I mean like do
you get support to say hey you know what
I wasn't I wasn't elected to spend a lot
of money it's very hard the the game is
kind of rigged against you and so what
we're trying to do with the club for
growth is elective majority of the
majority we want a majority of true
fiscal conservatives they can set the
direction for the country and so you
know it's a team sport and you have to
have people on your team that have the
same goals you do and so until the
culture changes and I really do think
this new crop of senators that hopefully
will take office in January will change
the culture of the Senate I think
there'll be you know 45 50 maybe 60 new
Republican members
they're running because of their concern
about the debt in the deficit we see a
lot of people that typically wouldn't
run for public office but they can't sit
and watch what's happening and so I hope
they don't get here and change their
views and kind of go Washington I don't
think they will but it's it's critical
we are at a tipping point and I think
that that is the next two elections are
critical to the future path we take well
I want to thank you Chris Chocola
president for the club for growth for
talking to reason TV today I'm Nicholas
you